In the lesson today, all of our examples came from natural language
understanding. But understanding is a very journal purpose cognitive task.
Natural language understanding is just one instance of understanding.
Understanding is about making sense of the world.
The world bombards us with data that comes in many forms. Acoustic, visual,
verbal, numerical. It's a very hard problem. How do we make sense of the world?
There are three sources of power. First, we exploit constraints about the world.
We know that the world behaves in certain ways. Whether it's a physical world or
the social world, or grammatical world.
Second, we have structured knowledge representations. The structured knowledge
representations in memory capture not just knowledge and its representation, but
the organization of knowledge, and there is power in that organization.
The power lies in the third part. Low level problem with processing helps us
activate these knowledge structures from memory. Once activated,
these knowledge structures generate expectations that make the processing top
down. And there's a lot of power in being able to generate those expectations.